wladimir putin sitzt zwar nicht physisch
mit am tisch aber irgendwie ist er doch
die ganze zeit dabei ich begrüße jetzt
ganz herzlich constantin golden zweig
vom russischen sender ntw
die reaktion in russland kam prompt mann
wies die kritik an russlands
außenpolitik natürlich zurück wie sehr
schmerzt es eigentlich den russischen
präsidenten dass er nicht bei diesen g7
die formal g8 waren dabei ist ich würde
sagen dass es für ihn ziemlich
schmerzhaft ist wenn man die psychologie
unseres präsidenten betrachtet die nicht
ganz so einfach ist dann soll man
behaupten dass ihr ziemlich beleidigt
ist dass man mit allen möglichen mitteln
und zwar so demonstrativ versucht zu
isolieren und zu zeigen dass russland
nicht einen teil dieser westliche welt
sei
deshalb will er beispielsweise schon
übermorgen sich mit dem italienischen
premier renzi treffen deshalb versucht
ihr auch an diesen tagen möglich
möglichst aktiv seine verbindungen zu
china und anderen asiatischen partnern
zu zeigen dass alles damit verbunden
wenn ich irgendwann ein angebot gäbe
wieder zurückzukehren an den g8 tisch
dann ist nicht eigentlich schon viel zu
viel porzellan zerschlagen hätte er
überhaupt ein interesse zurückzukehren
würde sagen schon das ist für ihn
wichtig und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
er in der tat glaubt daran dass es sich
lediglich um dieser verschiedene werte
handelt mit seinem zunächst muss das
ziemlich bekannt ist geht es für ihn um
irgendwelche geopolitische spiele
einflussbereiche hermann i tät von den
usa und so weiter und sobald er das
alles beherrscht wir hoffentlich glaubt
wäre er natürlich glücklich wieder mit
dabei am tisch zu setzen seine
zustimmungswerte in der bevölkerung sind
sehr sehr hoch quasi je mehr die
sanktionen greifen um so mehr sympathien
bringt die bevölkerung im entgegen wie
lange ist das system so noch tragbar
weil die st zum funktionieren ja
zumindest ein stück weit dass es kaum
vorstellbar wenn wir uns beispielsweise
an die späteren 18 jahren in der
sowjetunion
erinnern und an einem anderen
autoritären system konnte man damals
kaum vorstellen dass das system so
schnell zusammenbrechen wird und die
sanktion natürlich leisten einen
wesentlichen beitrag dazu aber niemand
kann jetzt voraussagen waren und wie es
geschieht und hauptsache was nach den
puschen kommen könnte
man hat gestern abend sehr sehr lange
über die ukraine krise bush gesprochen
man hat dann ein sehr einheitliches bild
gezeigt nämlich dass man bei den
sanktionen bleibt inzwischen sicher zu
langsam durch das wenn die situation in
der ost ukraine sich noch weiter
verschärft dass man die sanktion ein
stück weit auch noch verschärfen könnte
da scheint an den russischen präsidenten
aber nicht von seiner politik im don was
abzuhalten oder nein das ist für ihn
tatsächlich sehr wichtig beispielsweise
die gäste stellungnahme von kanzlerin
merkel war in allen medien mit dabei
dass die verantwortung an die einhaltung
der minsker vereinbarung nicht nur an
moskau sondern auch an tief liege das
haben alle russischen medien vor allem
staatlichen medien versucht zu
unterstellen das ist sehr wichtig ist
und in dem zusammenhang wird putin auch
hier obwohl er physisch abwesend ist
versuchen zu zeigen dass nicht nur
russland oder gar nicht rust und daran
schuld hat und dass die verschärfung der
sanktionen als ihn los ist und dass es
viel mehr negative konsequenzen für den
westen selbst bringt nicht für russland
dass wir die offizielle agentur sein
sprecher heute direkte die kritik
hieraus von schloss elmau zurückgewiesen
und gesagt der westen muss vor einigen
druck auf die ukraine ausüben denn auch
die müssen das münchner abkommen
einhalten wie sehr ist putin an einer
instabilität der region dort gelegen
ich würde sagen er hat großes interesse
daran dass die lage möglichst lange in
stabil bleibt
weil eigentlich
profitiert moskau natürlich noch sie
haben eingangs erwähnt dass er sich auch
anderen partnern zuwendet wie sehr wird
der asiatische raum für ihn umso
wichtiger je mehr im westen isoliert ist
er würde zumindest auch die offiziellen
ebene versuchen zu zeigen dass die heute
gewählt nicht mehr in die westliche und
in die östliche welt trainer getrennt
lassen kann und das zeigt ihr
beispielsweise schon übermorgen in
italien oder in ungarn oder in serbien
das ist keine grenzen zwischen dem
westen und ostern sei ob es in der tat
so oder nicht ist das ist für ihn nicht
so wichtig hauptsache für die
bevölkerung so ein welt darstellen zu
können
ein letzter satz noch zu seinem
verhältnis zu angela merkel sie scheinen
ja ein relativ gutes zu haben in
anbetracht der angespannten situation in
amerika heißt es immer wieder in
washington dass angela merkel obama
chefunterhändlerin sei im dialog mit
moskau wie ist das verhältnis zwischen
putin und merkel tatsächlich einzuordnen
traut er ist ja sonst mutmaßlich sehr
misstrauisch
ich würde das mit den beziehungen
beispielsweise zwischen brand und
breschnew vergleichen also keiner glaube
daran dass die werther dass die
grundlegende position sich irgendwie
irgendwann nehmen können werden aber
trotzdem ein versuch des pragmatischen
gespräches miteinander wir verstehen
dass trotz aller negativen konsequenzen
der ukraine krise es gibt immer noch
sehr viele internationale fragen die
sich ohne russland kaum lösen lassen ob
syrien iran nahost und so weiter und so
fort und dafür suchen nun da begreifen
wahrscheinlich beide dass sowohl merkel
als auch guten und deshalb trotz aller
schwierigkeiten müssen sie und versuchen
sie dieses gespräch fortzusetzen
herzlichen dank konstatierte golden
spike vom russischen fernsehsender ntw